truly into scientists she started out of
engineering then machine learning and
four pages credit the visual cortex she
studies small other things information
coding and computation in large
populations of neurons develops various
models most prominently perhaps Bayesian
models of cognition but also mentally
[Music]
so thank you very much for inviting me
I'm very happy to be in Berkeley so I'm
going to talk about
so okay so yes I've added mental illness
because it's really the field I am
interested in at the moment and we're
Bayesian series are seems to be quite
promising so this is going to be a quick
survey it's a huge field that I can't
cover in this time of course so the the
starting point is that in the world in
our experience there is uncertainty
everywhere at any moment in time
uncertainty and ambiguity and the idea
is that the brain we must deal with this
so there is uncertainty also because of
the limitation of our receptors because
the scenes can be ambiguous any moment
in time there are multiple
interpretations about the world and so
the brain must deal with this
uncertainty and to generate perceptual
representation and guide actions and
figure out what's out there and what's
the best action to take
so in this field we have the idea that
perception must work backwards to
extract the cause of noisy inputs and
this this is a process of unconscious
inference which we view as probabilistic
so we have this idea of the brain as a
sort of guessing machine and consciously
trying at every moment in time to figure
out what's the best explanation for
what's out there and what's the best
action to take so the the Bayesian brain
so takes a lot of ideas coming from
statistics based theorem of course which
initially was just a mathematical result
apparently its Laplace had already the
insight that human knowledge must come
from the accumulation of probabilities
and then we have helmets which is often
a attributed foreign standing this this
process of unconscious inference he was
looking at the human eye and understood
it as an optical instrument it was a
very poor optical instrument agree with
me but he had this idea that it received
incomplete information that the brain
must somehow complete based on previous
experience and so then in the in the 90s
people use select Jeff in turn Peter
Diana gets P and other people also used
ideas from from machine learning too
so view the brain as a sort of
generative model more recently these
ideas and I'll describe how came in to
experimental fields and in particular
psychophysics with a lot of success I
think I hope you will see that I think
in in perceptual so in visual
psychophysics and in particular and in
perception in general this Bayesian
approach has become quite mainstream it
has also spread in the theoretical world
and now I think there's also a lot of
interest to relate those theories with
with the physiology with the neural
substrate and that's proving much more
difficult and I'll discuss that as well
so Bayes theorem so I sure most of you
all of you know what Bayes theorem is
about so just to briefly summarize so in
Edinburgh we are very interested in the
weather and understanding whether it's
going to rain today which is very
unlikely and so so to compute the chance
that it will rain today the best thing
to do is to do two things to look at the
window and look at the evidence and so
so you wants to compute a variety that
it's going to rain today based based on
the evidence so you look at this
evidence and you have some knowledge of
the probability that the the clouds look
the way they do when you know it's going
to rain and so you can use this
knowledge and that's corresponds to the
likelihood but also you have a prior
belief that it's going to rain today and
that number is going to be very
different in Edinburgh and Los Angeles
and and so that's your prior and you
have to also take this information into
account and so Bayes theorem tells us
that the way to compute the posterior
probability the best way to compute this
is to multiply so the likelihood and the
prior normalize so Bayes theorem
corresponds to very intuitive ideas it's
in itself a very simple mathematical
result and concept
so the this Bayesian theory of the brain
then so suggest that the purpose of the
brain is to infer the state of the world
based on noisy data and it does that
using Bayesian inference and
representing information in the form of
conditional probability distributions so
everything in the brain would be
manipulated explicitly or implicitly and
probably implicitly in the form of a
probability distribution so if you're
interested in the position of an object
they're not going to represent that by a
number but by a probability distribution
where different locations have a
different probability so the idea then
is that the brain would learn and store
likelihoods and it would also learn and
stop priors and it's going to use those
internal models to come up with
posterior distribution which are so the
the the answers to the questions it
would be asking all the time and beliefs
about those hypothesis and so the brain
would be computing this prodigy
distributions and updating them
constantly and using the posterior as
the prior for next movement etcetera so
that's the general idea the benefits of
doing this are quite obvious it's it is
the best way to integrate information
which has some uncertainty in it to
integrate it over space and over time
and over also like different modalities
at different sensory cues different
modalities and combine all this
information without losing any of the
uncertainty that is attached to it so so
as so then to propagate this information
throughout the brain without committing
too early to particular interpretations
and losing information about there the
intrinsic reliability of this
information
so then the the idea is that so the
brain would work with these priority
distributions and only when fast it
would come up with a single number it
would collapse this priority
distribution with a single action a
single answer the way we do that is not
very clear but for example this could be
done by taking the maximum of this
distribution
it could be in or it could also be
taking a sample of this distribution and
it's not clear what the brain would do
so taking the max or the mean depends on
the cost function that you assume so you
are also have to to take into account
how costly it would be to make an error
or how much reward you would have if you
make the correct answer so either you
take a single and so the mean of the max
of some people think and we'll come back
to this that the way the brain works is
actually by sampling these materials
okay so in this stock so this is the
general framework so in this talk I am
going first to talk about the evidence
we have that people behave as Bayesian
observers and so I think most of it
initially came from the research on
multi-sensory integration so I describe
this briefly then I'm going to turn to
the concept of priors and asking the
question in perception envision in
particular what what priors the visual
system uses and how we can discover them
and all social learning questions around
the learning of these priors that's a
research we've been doing and other
people of course then I try to convince
you that these Bayesian ideas are maybe
an interesting new way to understand
mental illness with the idea that the
internal models that people would work
with would be different mental illness
and how again we can uncover those
differences in people with a mental
illness and finally I will end up with
trying to bridge those ideas which are
mostly at the computational behavior
level and the neural substrates I'll
talk a little bit about a controversy
some people believe this Bayesian
approach is never going to tell us in
anything interesting about how the brain
works and its substrate and an also
possible implementation ideas
isn't it too expensive for the brain to
keep probability distributions yes sir
so will it will come back to this a lot
of people now believe that so so first
of all only an approximation of Bayesian
inference is possible and also that
these approximations can be done with
Uri sticks and a lot of people see no
contradiction between those heuristics
and thinking that the brain still
there's something they'd be the
reference it also you can save
structurally in the ways without using
in the energy I mean it only is energy
when that part 5 is right when the
neurons fire so you can protect my story
you usually small the complexity that
people think is an achievable more than
energy cost per we will have no idea
about the energy cost I guess so do
people behave as Bayesian observers and
so we can we can use these Bayesian
hypothesis as a benchmark for
performance and and so the the way we
think about this is looking at where
this should be expressed and so we are
looking at Bayesian so people initially
talked about Bayesian optimality the way
we think about the basement optimality
is not as all in thinking that the human
brain is optimally designed or that we
can achieve the level of performance for
afforded by the uncertainty in the
physical stimulus like the movies we
don't see a collection of static images
we have all these illusions that are
related to the limitation of our
receptors so the way we think about
optimality in this sense is really about
uncertainty and about how the brain
takes into account uncertainty and
combine information which has different
uncertainty reliability and so the
questions where we want to see a
signature of this Bayesian functioning
is looking at how how neural
computations take into account the
uncertainty as a measure in the
measurement of each stage of processing
so combined uncertain information on
different stages of processing and also
combine current information with
previous information and in those for
those aspects the Bayesian theory mix
and I'll show you this very testable
predictions that we can you can test
behaviorally
so this has been done initially with a
lot of success when people looked at
multi-sensory integration and in
particular so a multi-sensory
integration for simultaneous information
coming from for example sound and vision
so how does the brain combine
information coming from different
modalities which may have different
reliability so we know we know that the
brain does that all the time
unconsciously we we've used information
coming from different modalities and
sometimes this leads to illusions
sometimes the modality is going to
dominate another modality and this will
need to illusion such as the
ventriloquism illusion or the McGurk
effect how many of you know that the
McGurk effect maybe I can show you just
in a few seconds it's quite fun have a
look at this what do you hear
but look what happens when we change the
picture and yet the sound hasn't changed
in every clip you are only ever hearing
bar with a B it's an illusion
it's a very strong aversion you can't do
anything provided so this mr. Xie is
going to say that he spent all his carry
on working on this and still he can't
control it so it's a very strong
illusion where vision is going to
dominate and transform the percept and
so similar effect which is happening in
ventriloquism is when you have someone
with a puppet and it pretends that it's
the puppet talking you know it's
actually talking in in using not its
mouth and and the puppet is moving the
mouse and you believe that the puppet is
movie is so mathematically you can try
to describe these things and it's it's
quite simple you can have very simple
models to describe these things so so
mostly here we are looking at a
situation where we are trying to mix
some vision and audition and and so we
can describe with the information coming
from vision and audition by so that
there are likely Goods and they can be a
little conflict between the two
modalities or no conflict yeah there is
so a conflict so for example you have
audition which giving this likelihood
and vision yeah centered in a different
place the the Bayesian theory will tell
you that the posterior distribution that
you will have about the location of the
object when you assume that the sound
and vision comes from the same object is
going to be linked to combining those
two distribution and so basically
multiplying those two gaussians and so
the posterior is going to be somewhere
in between those two gaussians in a way
that is going to depend on the width of
discussions and it's really about
multiplying Gaussian so if you know the
initial mean and
variants you actually know the final
mean and final variants and so if you
know the reliability by which people can
discriminate sound alone and vision
alone of the width of discussion and
where they would point if they are on a
vision of the sound you have the mean of
discussions you can predict exactly if
you have now vision an audition together
what people should perceive and so that
so again the mass is very simple you're
multiplying two gaussians and it gives
you the the mean of the resulting
Gaussian and so it's mean it's new mean
and it's new width and the result you
have is that the the mean of the
resulting Gaussian is going to be closer
to the Gaussian which is narrower which
is more precise and so you are this is a
linear combination so the the final
estimate is going to depend on the
initial estimate for each of the
modality weighted by the reliability of
these modalities so if vision is much
more precise the final estimate is going
to be pushed to once vision that's
what's happening in the McGurk effect or
ventriloquism and you also know about
the width of discussion and this tells
you the precision by which people can
discriminate based on the two modalities
together and it tells you that this
discrimination threshold or the just
noticeable difference based on the two
modalities together is going to be
better finer then with only one of the
two modalities okay so these are very
clear predictions there's no new
parameter and you can you can test these
things you can so that's what initially
and some banks have done in 2002 so they
looked not at vision and audition
certain vision and touch and they had an
experimental paradigm with so people had
to to measure the width of this object
which they could touch with a phantom
cloth and they could also see and the
noise in the visual display was
manipulated so there was different
levels of uncertainty in the visual
display the there was no so the level of
noise was fixed in in in the haptic
display and so they could first measure
finally people could discriminate
which based on touch then based on
vision and they could play those
equations to have the predictions but
what would happen if you have touch and
vision together and test whether those
predictions would reveal correct what
they found is that they did so for
example here if we look at the
discrimination threshold they look first
at the discrimination threshold if there
is only touch and that's the that's the
the red line then if there's only vision
these are the blue dots so in vision you
have different level of noise different
level of uncertainties and so the
distribution threshold is gonna increase
when you have more and more noise in the
visual display so from those you can
form a prediction with the Bayesian
theorem and that's the gray area and
then they tested that by putting touch
and vision together and these are the
pink dots and they find that so the pink
dots fell into the the grey area so
validating the prediction and also it
also shows that so one modality is much
more reliable than the other so here our
vision is much more reliable than the
other then the combined estimate follows
the more reliable estimates were here
vision and vice versa here vision is
very noisy and and touch is more precise
so the final estimates for lose
completely touch so that was a very
exciting at the time and it was taken as
and written in this way that that people
then we are based in optimal in that
sense and and so could combine the
different modalities take into account
the uncertainty of each modality and
instantly switch to to get an estimate
which which was waiting the reliability
of each modality
okay and so so that was an important
result back then and I think it was the
start of a huge field which is now a
huge field people have replicated this
kind of result in a variety of paradigm
so first in so with vision and audition
but now people have extended to all
sorts of modalities and finding very
similar result they so often it's not
you you find results that are close to
the predictions but not not exactly so
it's slightly suboptimal and how
suboptimal is still optimal it's a it's
not clear but you find different degrees
in sub sub optimality people oh yes so
often vision dominates but also people
have found domains where it's not true
anymore in particular in the temporal
domain that's a an illusion so here you
are asked how many flashes you can see
how many circles you can see in the
right as well and if all goes well you
have a bit of an illusion where you see
two which is actually just due to the
sound there's only one one visual flash
so in the in the temporal domain sound
is going to dominate over vision and so
people have also described the
disillusions and so the reverse of this
it's the reverse of the ventriloquism
here where it's actually audition that
dominates a vision and how we can
explain now
so as I've said the another now this
field is uh is getting really big and
it's not my domain of expertise it's
very interesting and also people have
extended it to situations where it's not
clear whether you have to fuse different
modalities so clearly if the distance
between the two modalities vision and
audition increases there's a point where
you don't want to fuse the two sources
and function of information you want to
segment them and decide that they are
two objects not one object and so on
there's some research showing that you
can also explain what people do in
situations like this by with models
where people not only in the location of
the causes but also the cultural
structure so what people do is like a
sort of model comparison where they
would compute the location of the
objects under the assumption that is
only one source or two sources and then
the the final estimate would be the
estimate given by each model times the
probability of each model so there are
also models like this but ya know
there's a there's an inference about the
probability that each each model is true
given the evidence that you have before
them there was also models that that
looked at
so clearly the way you've used different
modalities depends on the modalities and
so there are some modalities that you
are happier to hues than others and so
people have thought that this was also
due to priors which incorporated
knowledge about when information is
usually synchronous or not
so there are situations where humans are
not optimal and so this is just an
example there's also some research
looking at development and it's it's
known that things change with age and in
particular it looks like the behavior
becomes adult like in children only when
they reach something like 10 years of
age and before that integration that
they don't integrate as much so that was
for the first part sensory integration I
think it was the start of yeah don't do
this integration that you talked about
vision don't I mean there's there's
experiments with kittens with a there's
I think there's a critical period some
people have no normative explanations
for that and the reason it would be that
the different modalities are maturing
and that you still you you don't want to
fuse or the assignment and maybe in
childhood you you want to keep access to
all modalities separately when they
continue to match otherwise it would be
too confusing somehow but it's it's a
good point but I yeah
welcome back to this my finger control
versus I guess but learning at least so
the the second topic I'd like to talk
about here is whether brains form a
representation of the past information
that we can think of in terms of a prior
belief and combine it optimally with
current information
so there's also lot of research
regarding this kind of questions clearly
so the question we want to know is how
the brain is making use of previous
information and what kind of prize is
working with reali to look at this
priors we need to look at situations of
uncertainty so it's it's in situation
where we where we are very little income
information that we are going to rely on
our past experience just like if we are
waking up in the middle of the night and
we have to find our way we are going to
rely on our memory about the room
clearly how much the prior is going to
influence the posterior depends on the
width of these distributions so we want
to look at situations of for large
uncertainty or ambiguity and these
priors we are looking for to make sense
in the Bayesian sense should reflect the
statistics of the censoring world so the
search there should be a summary of past
experience but it's not clear on which
timescale we are thinking about that's
also a question we can ask which are the
time scales that matter
so to look at this phone of questions
people are often turned to visual
illusions so situations often certainty
or ambiguity like this one where if
you've never seen that before you will
probably see your lake when there's no
lake and so things like this we think
tells us are all about the assumptions
the the brain is making and so the brain
is very it's very happy thinking here
the trees are vertical this person is
vertical and reconstructing everything
so that remains true even if it's wrong
and so they are people have looked at a
lot of illusions thinking that these
illusions gives us insights about the
sort of assumptions that the visual
system makes and people have identified
a list of priors that the brain seems to
be working with our expectations that
the brain has it has an expectation that
lights come from above above us and
that's how it is interpreting these
shaded objects in terms of convexity or
concavity
yeah if light came from below we should
interpret things in the opposite way so
the light come from above seems to be a
very strong prior the brain is using to
recover 3d dimensions out of 2d images
there's also a research looking at the
perception of orientation and looks like
the brain expects things to be mostly
particular horizontal there are
illusions which are related to seeing
things as being more vertical or
horizontal than they really are which
also would be true in the natural world
there are illusions related to
smoothness or behavior really to
smoothness we expect things to be smooth
in space and smooth in time and again we
are happier to reconstruct things as
being smoother than they really are and
also David Neil has worked on priors
related to symmetry so we also expect
things to be symmetrical and the
illusion is related to that another
prior that people have worked on
including us is the notion that we
expect things to be mostly static or
moving only slowly which would also
explain the rough illusions reported in
the motion literature and so these are
these are these illusions have been
recently formalized in Bayesian terms
and models can pay answer to behavior
I'll just describe a few things along
these lines so there is so I've said
this literature about the the slow speed
prior so initially there are literature
about the slow speed Pryor was inspired
by this problem of
the aperture problems many of you
probably know about the aperture problem
the aperture problem is the idea that if
you have a line segment behind an
aperture which is what we think visual
receptive field see we unambiguously see
the motion of this as being
perpendicular to the line even if in
reality it is an infinity of
interpretations that would be consistent
with this image and so you can ask
yourself why the brain chooses this
interpretation in such a strong way
again here you can't do anything about
this even if you know the actual motion
here you can't control it and and one
explanation which came initially from
psychologists was that maybe the the
interpretation that we choose which is
perpendicular to the orientation of the
line it actually corresponds to the
interpretation with slowest speed so
maybe somehow the brain expects slower
speeds and and when it has to choose
between different interpretation will
choose the interpretation with slower
speed and so this idea has been has been
used recently and very elegantly by the
the group of Eros eventually and
recently anymore
but it there's a lot of different
allusions in the motion literature so
sadly this link doesn't work anymore but
a lot of illusions which are related to
when you change the contrast you see
things as moving in a different
direction
which are related to this aperture
problem and so arrow showed that with an
escalator vison illusion they showed
that with a very simple model which uses
a prior on slow speed you can give a
unifying explanation for all these
different motion illusions that before
them had been explained by different
models so the view then all these motion
illusion I illusions as optimal concepts
because they use this prior on on slow
speed which they think makes sense given
that
in the world things are mostly static or
moving slowly
so so that was an influential paper in
the field the showing that we can
explain the revolutions with these miss
priors yep if I move the light very
slowly maybe I don't have to add a
correction perceptional correction
because it's already looks slow but you
know how these effects are being
influenced by the speed of change so
we've looked at and I described this
we've looked at situations where things
are moving fast on the contrary and and
look at whether people are going to
adapt update their prior to account for
this new statistics and we've we find
that they do so people if you show them
a lot of fast stuff they will end up
with a prior for faster motion but it's
not completely clear analysts it was not
clear at all then how this prior relates
to experience and and how flexible it is
and how it relates also to the
statistics of the world which will be
difficult to measure
so they went on so this is the work by
Alan stock and in Simoncelli and so in
this in this work they had assumed a
Gaussian prior and showed that this was
consistent so the result was consistent
with a lot of these illusions
qualitatively but they went on and they
decided to use this kind of framework to
actually measure in individual
participants the prior that would be
consistent with their behavior so by
fitting this Bayesian model so so here
and they look at an experiment where
people have to do discrimination between
so the speed of different objects and so
they compare speed and the different
level of contrasts or uncertainty and so
based on data like this and fitting
Bayesian model with a with a flexible
now speed prior what they do is then
measure an individual participant the
shape of this speed prior so the idea
here was to test whether people really
use the Gaussian prior or some some
other form of a prior and also look at
the variability between different
peoples prior and and whether by looking
at models like this we could actually
quantify variability between different
people and so in this this paper they
they give a sort of methodology to so
based on experimental data and
psychophysics fit those Bayesian models
and extract for each individual the
Bayesian prior that is most compatible
whether with the behavior so that's
interesting because it means we have a
new tool to look at individual
variability and look at the internal
model that people are using that is
consistent with their behavior
and then you can ask a lot of questions
when you can do that is it's also you
can ask whether this this prior than
that you are measuring in people's head
kind of whether it makes sense and
particular whether it makes sense
compared to the statistics of the visual
world and so in this in this work that's
what they did they compared the so they
look at orientation here and they look
at so judgment about tilt and we know
that judgment about tilt are very biased
towards the Cardinals and oblique as
well and and so based on their
measurements they could extract a
Bayesian prior that was compatible with
the with the behavior and they compared
this prior with the statistics of
orientation in a large collection of
photographs and they showed that
qualitatively at least the prior that
people seem to be using in terms of
orientation seems to fit with the
statistics of orientation in natural
scene statistics so quantitatively at
least it looks like the prior papers
have in the head matches with the
statistics of the natural world in this
case so that's the kind of question you
can ask we were interested in another
type of question which is whether people
from priors all the time whether whether
we have kind of fixed priors for this
natural seen statistics mystics or
whether whether in the new context we
would form new priors that we would use
as well and so to do this
we've looked at very simple experiment
involving motion perception so so we add
people coming in the lab and looking at
clouds of dots moving on the screen and
people had to do two things they add to
estimate the motion direction so they
had to tell us in which direction those
dots were moving and the contrast was
going to go really low there's a
staircase in contrast is going to be
more and more uncertain ambiguous what's
going on and we also asked people to
tell us whether they've actually seen
dots or no dots and so in this
experiment so here it looks like this
so people have to move an arrow to tell
the direction of the dots and they have
to do then this detection task whether
they've seen dots or no dots and so and
they do that for for two hours on two
consecutive days so one hour each and so
what we don't tell the participants is
that not all motion directions are
equally likely so in these experiments
two motion directions - 32 and 32 are
more frequently presented than the other
motion directions so what we are asking
is whether if they are statistic like
this whether participants are going to
learn implicitly that some motion
directions are more likely to appear
than others and if they do how this is
going to bias the perception
so I'm not going to go into all the
details but what we find is that people
are not conscious that some motion
directions are more likely than others
if we forced them to report about the
dis environment that they've been
presented with there's no idea they
think it's all the same but if we look
at their behavior we find that the they
have learned that some that motion
directions are more likely than others
to appear and this strongly biases their
perception they become better and faster
at detecting those most frequent
Direction also there are some some some
trials where there's actually nothing on
the screen but we forced people to tell
us the direction of motion if they've
seen something and to tell us whether
they've they've seen something or not
and on some trials even if there's
nothing on the screen people believe
they have seen something and when when
they did they have also reported some
motion directions so we can look at this
and that's the black line when people
think they've seen something when there
was nothing often it was in the
direction of the expected motion
direction yeah we are for did everything
in - so 32 is the the most frequent
direction so we interpret this as a form
of very simple origination there's
nothing on the screen but people end up
originating what they expect should
happen
tell you the detective motion so
everybody does but on a very unknown
number of trials and the number varies
and also look at the viability of that
yeah yeah so the black line for example
is the report the direction well that's
the situation when they tell us I've
seen something red is the situation
where so that's the direction the report
but if they've told us correctly they
did not see anything they don't have to
perform the discrimination task but if
they are just like passively watching
the screen like do they update the
priors as well just so we've never done
that I assume so
so we also showed that so they end up
initiating what they expect and we find
that this effect was fast to develop it
was a matter of minutes really 200
trials that people start to develop
these simple kind of hallucinations and
also so in the trials where there was
actually some emotion on the screen and
we look at the estimation answer and
what we find is that they are strong
biases and people report the emotion
direction as being most similar to the
most frequent direction than it really
is so when there was nothing on the
screen didn't you see Nick what they
expect when there is something on the
screen they tend to see reality as being
more similar to what they expect and it
really is so then with this you can you
can fit Bayesian models and the idea is
that whether you can explain this in
terms of people forming a prior belief
and combining this prior belief with
evidence and so mostly that's what we
show so we fit Bayesian models family of
them we also fit different models that
are more like decision biases models and
by fitting those models we can also
extract so the likelihood and the priors
that corresponds best with people's
behavior and so what we find is a lot of
viability but usually we find that so we
can extract priors for each individual
and they they correspond to rough
approximation of the stimulus statistics
we do a lot of model comparison to
convince ourselves that the Bayesian
explanation is the best and and it is at
least it's it's the one that is most
elegant that describes the data in less
parameter
so so that's an experiment that if we've
done some time ago and we've continued I
think it's it's interesting because it
shows that participants learn very
quickly about the statistics of the
visual environment they have its
unconscious we don't know that we are
doing this but it still biases I
experienced we originated what we were
what we expect and we see reality as
being more similar to what we expect and
it really is and this behavior is
consistent with Bayesian inference with
people working whether learns prior
which is far from being a perfect
description of the stim statistics but a
rough approximation with a lot of funny
ability oh this is very interesting to
see the priors developing in time yes so
there's also something we are we are
looking at because I attempt to see the
following evidence is strengthening my
prior belief yeah sort of confirmation
bias County yeah so we are looking and
dynamics the problem yeah is it's it's
it's very fast and those Irish nations
with in particular we don't have a lot
of them so the data is quite fast so it
it's not easy but this is something we
are looking at at the moment so other
types of questions you can ask related
to this and so I'll come back to this
experiment as well is whether all types
of priors are flexible you can update
them or some are fixed and so there was
some debates initially about the light
from above prior for example so this
assumption the light come from above
visit something is fixed or can you
change this so people are done in the
60s I think experiments in chickens that
were raised when in an environment where
lights come from below and looking at
how they interpret 3d objects and they
found that chickens never adapt they're
still single so I think initially people
thought that this was genetically wired
and maybe it is in chickens I don't
think it has been replicated by
in humans dope so people have interested
in these questions and in humans it
looks like people can update and so this
was shown initially by Adams graph and
announced in its nature neuroscience
they look at an experiment where you
have those 3d shaded objects and you can
see them but you can also touch them and
you can introduce a conflict between the
vision and the and the touch and you can
make whatever is convex concave and vice
versa and in this experiment they show
so with this strong feedback that people
and adjusting slightly not completely
but they end up changing the prior by
the light they just add so there is no
Bayesian modeling involved they were
just add chickens raised in this
environment with light so dark
environment where light comes from below
and then they looked at the behavior
they add objects a bit like this and
when I then looked at how they picked it
and how they behaved aha from their
behavior hadn't interpreted the 3d shape
so we've looked at this again so what's
interesting in this experiment this
shows flexibility but this is a
situation with very strong conflict we
looked at the same kind of question but
now with a slow-speed prior and in a
situation where you don't have a
conflict you just have exposure you know
even a feedback so the question we asked
in this experiment is similar to the
question I had is so people have a
slow-speed prior it looks but what if
you are testing them in an environment
where things go fast are they going to
end up adjusting for this and so
basically we played with this motion
illusions which are related to this low
speed prior so we measured those
illusions fast and then we showed so
this is like the aperture program I
don't see but this is moving and because
it's so this is an area of lines and
they are moving coherently and because
of the aperture problem you are biased
to see motion as being perpendicular to
the orientation of the line but so if
you are showed that for a long time at a
faster speed and then I test you again
which is what we did what we find is
that after a few days people end up
having the opposite percept so instead
of being of seeing motion as
perpendicular to the line they see it as
being more often oblique and so this
which is consistent with now assuming
that speed is faster than the motion
will display and so so we thought it's
interesting because yeah it's just
exposure people add up just by exposure
the speed prior they are working with
and so we did the modeling as well to
see here how this speed prior then
changed from day to day
so flexible flexible priors even fast
for the what we thinks correspond to
statistics of the natural environment so
that's also a field that is growing and
there's a lot of questions you can ask
with this sort of paradigms the
questions I've been interested in and
other people as well are what are the
limits of prior learning if you have
very complex priors often people have
unimodal Gaussian priors we have bimodal
but can you increase the complexity of
the spires and and things which still
some people would still learn so how
many priors can we learn simultaneously
or so there are very interesting
questions to ask about generalization or
transfer so here for example when people
adapt this low speed prior and they go
out of the experiment are they going to
use this new prior for looking at cars
or or not and so people have found Wendy
McAdams and Wendy Adams in particular
that people learn priors for specific
contexts and they keep it for that
context and one so when they go out of
the lab they they use the price they had
before so we are interested there's a
lot of unknowns here where the price is
specific to stimulus tasks experimental
context people are also interested in
the time scale of learning including
laws and so on learning all these priors
and how we can measure that or so people
have described the fact that maybe
people are not really learning priors in
the form of provided distributions but
maybe sometimes simpler URI sticks but
just summing the mean of the past five
say trials can also explain the data so
it's simple heuristics also can often
explain the data violence and that's an
interesting literature about what kind
of a heuristics than the brain
so just yet finish up a bit about this
part so I think in psychophysics yeah
complexity it also refers to like how
deep the trees or something like that
how because complexity also in our case
no it's really the shape of this and
also Luigi what has done is really
playing with the shape of this
distribution so like the motion
distribution here and looking at how
finally people can roundish in this
shape but of course yes particularly if
you start asking about structures and
people the prize people have about the
structure of information yeah this is
all kind of other types of complexity
you can think of your article
often we use very simple updates when we
get different data than what we already
know I think there is a little bit yeah
and also when people look at I've seen I
don't even fortunately but people
looking at weather when people learn
about structures weather with learning
people learn about changes in structures
or changing in parameters and but it I
think it's just the start of this kind
of research and often we are limited in
the model we can fit by the nature of
the data
these experiments visual all the other
types of sensory biases the big
investigation no no I probably vision is
dominant research but they there's a lot
of things also in the temporal domain
and also yes and so he must have domain
no it's by no means not only vision
vision is welcome from but it has
expanded for the so the last question is
the most important not I mean so we saw
lots of priors here think the lecture
and the question is because the brain
uses Bayesian model in order to you know
to predict what is happening or some
other model all right so I'll come back
to that and the question whether the
brain is Bayesian and whether that makes
any sense at all to ask that question so
what do we learn I think in this field
Bayesian models are thought at least as
elegant description of behavior so
efficient efficient tools in terms of
benchmark but also yeah efficient tools
for describing behavior the assumptions
are often transparent people think
that's one of the advantage of these
models I think the behavior we find in
vision but not only in vision is that
it's clear that brains take into account
uncertainty combined information in a
way dependent on the reliability of the
different sources of information it's
clear that previous but in a way it's
trivial that previous knowledge is
taking into account and that that's
previous knowledge is updated at all
time and taking into account when
interpreting new information those
priors that we can measure with those
tools are consistent with some
approximation of the statistics of INRA
of the environment what we find as all
experimental research we find a lot of
viability and we find that these are
only like rough approximation of the
statistics of the environment but they
seem it seems to make sense from the
dissipation point of view what we find
in general so and a lot of people
repond that the Bayesian model very
easily fit very well the data they see
there's a there's a lot of interested
interest as well in deviations from
optimality so I I don't know there's not
a lot of work trying to understand the
reasons behind sub optimality although
that there is in trying to relate to
these heuristics but they it this is
more of an more of an open question how
how much a sub optimality is there hot
can we quantify it and how can we relate
it to heuristics but for example as I
said in multi sensory integration we
find differences in development and that
ideally that will give us constraints
about the machinery that is behind of
course that's the hope so I'm
particularly interested in the fact that
those priors we can measure now in
different people so the prior beliefs
but also cost functions likelihood and
this give us a new tool maybe to
quantify inter-individual variability
and so that we can use to look at
different groups for example and as I
will transition to maybe mental illness
yes
yeah I'm just curious like when you
speak biasing optimality you always like
the way understand useless you know
she's right and these like Gaussian
distributions are not maintained
and yet you have many examples of
optimization yeah I come with the are so
lucky by guessing what are the true
coordinates used by the brain even
though that even too many possible so
I'll come back to that this there's been
a lot of literature has worried about
differentiating basil and optimality and
probabilistic and maybe the notion of
optimality is actually not a very good
question to ask I will come back to you
as well because so we can fit the
Bayesian model to about anything and so
so that that's not that's not because we
can fit a Bayesian model that we can say
the system is optimal but I'll come back
to this maybe but certainly we're not
interested in only a Gaussian
distribution yes so I'd like to describe
a little bit thinks about mental illness
so that's a so computation in psychiatry
as it's now called is a really new field
which is growing really fast in the past
five years and this is a lot of
literature with a lot of open questions
and so we think Bayesian models are
interesting in this field because maybe
we can show if you think of people
interpreting the world through the lens
of their internal model then maybe we
can describe mental illness in terms of
people having simply different internal
models and maybe with those kind of
tools we can try to measure those
differences and how they have
consequences in the behavior so for some
people including me maybe we can
describe mental illness in terms of
differences in the models of the world
that people brain are working with for
example different priors so for example
in depression maybe people have
pessimistic priors well you could have a
paranoid paranoid priors in
schizophrenia price and mistrust and
borderline or so people have looked
Pryor's about control controllability
and depression the idea that you don't
control much about the outcomes in the
world
so maybe different beliefs people are
work with different beliefs and I can
explain different different disorders
and also there is the idea that maybe
the way people combine incoming
information with prior beliefs
difference in mental disorders and in
particular there's the idea that in
schizophrenia and autism in particular
the way the way incoming information is
is combined with prior belief is somehow
imbalanced and so either so in general
it's thought that the weight given to
the prior is actually weaker in autism
and maybe stronger in schizophrenia at
least for cognitive price so this is a
new area of research and there's a lot
of interest in from psychiatry because
it goes well with the idea of of beliefs
that that would be different and and the
idea of measuring those differences in
belief in different kind of population
as well I think in this field that we
view mental illness as possibly an
impairment in prediction which would be
due to having a distorted internal model
of the world which possibly would be due
to either having having had a different
experience for example trauma or
impairment in learning possibly due to
interments in the biological substrate
of of learning for example dopamine or
any deer so that's the kind of ideas
that are quite popular at the moment and
that we want to test
so so these ideas have been a published
track in the best journals so for
example in schizophrenia so it's been
thoughts that the Bayesian so there will
be basing impairment in schizophrenia
it's quite messy but the bottom line
that people propose is that
the the the idea mostly is that sensory
priors would be too weak and so that
would lead to a changing and unstable
ground where are things would be
perceived as being salient when they
should not so at the perceptual level
the price would be weaker and maybe to
compensate for that at the community
level the price would be stronger so the
beliefs would have more impact on the
experience and that could explain ERISA
Nations where people would perceive
there are beliefs are delusions where
they also have very strong belief that
they can't change and there is some
experimental literature that that is
consistent with this in particular so if
you look at sensory illusions again you
find differences in schizophrenia and
you find that people with schizophrenia
are less sensitive to visual illusions
for example in control and of course
there was belief that higher community
level seems to be stronger than control
so people think about in terms of in
parent predictions in schizophrenia this
doesn't work anymore and very similar
models have been proposed in autism yeah
and the idea is that in autism the the
sensory priors would be weaker the
reality is it could strike something
surprise we look at we look at
schizotypy so interestingly we look at
we are going to measure schizotypy in
individuals and to find people with high
schizotypy we look at people with
paranormal beliefs and to recruit them
we ask people who think they have a
different connection with the world and
family experience so well it's the same
thing is the literature about this
whether it is same thing no different
so in autism this this idea as well that
the the sensory priors would be weaker
and so this is consistent with the fact
that we know there is deficits in
contextual integration in autism and
also that often people with autism can
be overwhelmed with the sensory input as
if they can't inhibited by the context
so in the literature there are proposals
that the sensory prize will be bigger
but it's also been noted that maybe it's
not that which is happening but maybe
what's happening is that their
likelihood the precision of the visual
sensory representation is actually it's
more precise so the likelihood would be
sharper and that would have the same
kind of consequences but it's a
completely different model we're here
and then people believe that sensory
precision will be actually higher in
autism
yes there is some comorbidity and in our
data we measure a schizotypy and a Q and
we find a correlation but this still
think sort should be completely
different disorders of course but both
have social consequences and so that's
what you see as well in in the
questionnaires in this course
so maybe the priors are too weak or
maybe their likelihood are sharper also
other people have proposed that actually
the priors are maybe similarly sharp or
narrow or broad but they are maybe more
rigid and there's a lack of transfer of
priors so the bottom line is that this
is a flourishing field but it's very
qualitative its psychiatrist like it's a
loss because it's a new way to describe
things and me and other people are
interested in in trying to say to see if
if this is actually quantitatively
testable and how we can do that and also
of course how useful that would be so
the type of things we've been doing is
use that experiment again that I've
described so the exact same experiment
was just one hour and a bit shorter to
make it a bit easier and now we've with
testing we are testing different kind of
populations so patients with
schizophrenia at the moment we have 22
we are testing people with clinical
diagnosis of autism and they're just
starting we just have eight at the
moment but also we have a larger cohort
of people who are LC these are students
but we've tried to find people with high
IQ autistic traits or high schizotypes
by looking at people with paranormal
beliefs and things like that and and
have them into our experiment and so we
think it's interesting compared to what
has been done before because now we are
really in the situation where people are
learning new priors and we can see the
impact of this price on perception and
and also we have a quantitative Bayesian
modeling where we can we can really test
those ideas so I'm not going to describe
all of it so in a nutshell what we find
is that the schizophrenic patients
behave very similarly to the control we
find a slight difference in
of hallucinations and that they actually
originates less than the controls but
mostly the data is very clean and they
they show beautiful statistical learning
one reason might be the medication and
add those those patients we can do our
experiment are well and they've been
well for a long time so there might be
differences but with the number of
patients we have they are really subtle
in schizotypy similarly we don't find
anything interesting interesting at all
but with hu we have some interesting
results so I'm going to show this so
this is again it's LC participant but we
are now confirming the same thing in
patients so we are happy with our cohort
because we have quite a large range of
scores of AQ or so hu compared to
schizotypy is much better defined so
people agree that this questionnaire
which has 50 questions the AQ is a good
descriptor of autism even if it's not a
diagnostic tool it is accepted as a good
way to describe autism whereas
schizotypy i has many different
questionnaires we don't have a good
correlation between the scores it's much
messier so we have a range of scores
some of them are actually at the
clinical level even if these are and see
people and what we find so I'll go I'll
go fast but what we find is a number of
differences so mostly we find less bias
we find less noise in the estimation and
we find less hallucination in people
with higher IQ and so we are we can
quantify this in terms of correlation
with aq and again so we find we find
less bias less noise in the estimation
performance and less so a smaller number
of origination which is so consistent
with the previous literature but the
fact that maybe prior beliefs who would
have less influence in people er
autistic traits
but we can do better than this because
now we have this Bayesian model so we
can look at whether it's really it's the
the basement prior which is different or
the likelihood we can also test all the
models of course what we find
interestingly and unexpectedly
is that the difference we have is not in
the prior but it's it's more in the
likelihood so it looks like the behavior
of people with autistic traits yeah is
more precise now likely with the shopper
and it's because it's sharper that the
influence of the prior is weaker it's
not that they don't learn the prior but
it's it has less influence on the
percept and so that's interesting it's
also going to be controversial because
it supports this a nonsense very
precision model that has been debated
for a long time whether people with
autism actually perceive the world in
the final way and then controls and in
which kind of situations are very messy
literature interesting if you look at
the data in terms of discrimination
performance for example you find results
in different ways and some some people
find better discriminability some people
less it depends for motion depends on
whether you have first-order motion or
second-order of orientation you find
something else the data is actually
missing but it's been there for a long
time and people really believe that's
that's irking but now also we need to we
need to test actual patients with autism
which have much more severe autism and
see if this is due to the fact that
these are actually very very highly
functioning students actually I will be
different with people who actually in in
parents on high by their autism
but um I think it's an interesting new
zone
so that's that's for this part so I
wanted to show it as an example of what
we can do to to look so to use those
Bayesian tools to test these current
theories which exist in psychiatry now
quite prominent at the moment to test if
so there is the claim that Bayesian
inference whatever it means would be
impaired so we can try to test that all
may be quantify differences in internal
models in in making priors and
likelihood and see what exactly is
different so making some progress in
that ultimately as I'm sure you know
there is a bit of a crisis in psychiatry
with even the classification of diseases
people really hope that this kind of
tools sonar only Bayesian tools may be
also reinforcement learning all the
computational tools will give us a way
to describe behavior differently and
maybe revisit the classification of
disease have a vocabulary which we can
use across the dimensions of diseases
and which will be useful in describing
differences so I'm interested in the
fact you didn't find anything it was
do you know that walpert paper about
schizophrenic and force escalation
basically estimating the effects of
their own actions and if you think that
that might have something to do with it
in terms of passively sort of sensing
something versus we did expect based on
previous research that we would have
strong differences with schizophrenic
patients yeah people it's again the
literature is very messy but maybe
people looking at visual illusions have
found differences even even in the
visual domain and things which are
similar to us sometimes strong
differences of oh let's say yet some
differences have been reconfirmed we
expected initially to find more
differences in schizotypy than in the SD
yeah some people think ultimately maybe
we can use those tools even for
diagnosis and in the clinic but we are
way far from that but that's the
ultimate goal so I just finished with
all the messy questions so what does
this tell us about the brain which i
think is interesting but it's it's a lot
of messy question so not everybody is
convinced about the values or the
interest of this Bayesian framework it's
been debate in the literature and that's
a quote from this paper about us and
Davis our main thesis is that Bayesian
modeling both in practice and in
principle is a misguided approach to
studying the mind and the brain and I
think some people believe that we are
never going to learn anything about the
substrate of the brain and how these
things are really implemented in the
neurobiology and so I'll describe a
little bit the controversy which i think
is interesting and i think he's making
the field progress as well I think the
main criticism is that this framework
has made little predictions on your
science me that can be testable in
neuroscience and the typical reply to
this is that it was never meant to so we
saw those levels of Mara before in a
previous lecture so so as you know amaz
described that so the three level of
analysis the computation level
algorithmic level implementation level
GRE this Bayesian approach lies at the
computational level and so whether it
can actually constrain or predict
anything at will be the implementation
level is not clear at all and it really
meant to describe this at this level and
so the the reply to this controversy by
like the Bayesian campus to say that the
Bayesian models were never are not
intended to provide mechanistic or
process accounts of cognition
and and and the other thing is of course
that nobody believes that exact Bayesian
influence will be implemented so it has
to be an approximation of Bayesian
inference and so how Bayesian an
approximation of Bayesian inference is
going to be it's not far from vision you
can say when you are an approximation
it's not so different so these papers
are quite fascinating because they are
really aggressive so the points that
have been discussed are points regarding
optimality there was a the notion of
optimality was quite confusing in the
initial paper and what actually was
claimed so initially people have found
Bayesian optimality everywhere in in
babies in frogs so the question is what
we meant by optimality when we were
fitting those Bayesian models and so
clearly it's not that the system is
optimally designed but it's it's more
that so the combination of the noisiest
inputs is optimal this the the way
uncertainty is taken into account
conforms Bayesian inference that that's
what people meant really there are very
important and difficult questions about
falsifiability and so again the the
critique is that you can fit any kind
any data with a Bayesian model if you
have the right prior loss function and
so so clearly then it became clear that
the question of asking whether the brain
is Bayesian doesn't make any sense
and so the replies then is that the
Bayesian approach is a framework a
framework is typically not falsifiable
only implement different like
implemented models which have different
parameters or structures it can be
compared and then be falsified but then
the question is if it's a framework what
is it what is the alternative framework
and I
good answer to that so clearly what we
have to do is not ask whether the brain
is Bayesian but like try to compare a
family of models and and find the magis
time most compatible what the brain does
and it's in those details of how the
model some way that we can get
information it's not in the claim about
Bayesian normality so similarly to this
yet one critic was that those models
were not compared to previous models
often and and the reply to this was that
yes but previous models were a caste at
a different level they were either the
algorithmic or the implementation level
and so it doesn't make any sense to
compare them they might be completely
compatible so you can you can have a
neural network using back prop say that
is actually going to do an approximation
of Bayesian inference
another critique which I find difficult
is that whether people are just
reinventing the wheel and it's just a
new vocabulary to describe things that
people knew before and so I guess the
replies that is so useful vocabulary
that's inside but clearly what we call
priors other people have called memory
or plasticity and so and so the link
between the different vocabularies it's
not clear how to integrate knowledge as
it was described before with this new
framework and finally the most difficult
critic I guess is the lack of
neurobiological predictions and again so
the the answer to this which is still
it's an unsatisfying though I think is
that this approach is not incompatible
with the previously proposed mechanistic
model not even models that would be
based on simple heuristics and so the
Bayesian campi I replied to that there
isn't it needs to be nothing
intrinsically Bayesian about algorithm
that approximate Bayesian inference but
again that means that in terms of the
prediction the signature we should we
should find about this Bayesian
computation in the neurobiological
substrate it's not clear what we should
look for
Sajid then I have a few slides about
still the the fact that people are still
working on trying to bridge this
Bayesian approach and the neurobiology
so there exist models and so first of
all there's a question about
representation how would neuron
represent priority distributions and so
Peter Latham will be here and so if you
don't have and they can talk about this
much better than me but there are
different models and some assume that
priority distributions are really
represented entirely or try me in the in
the brain either the priority
distribution or maybe the log of the
probability or maybe the way those
priority distributions are represented
is by representing the parameters of
this distribution maybe using your basis
function but the idea is that the
priority distribution itself is
represented probably implicitly in those
models other people think that the way
the brain work is really using sampling
and so the the activities we represent
and and we've seen had also in previous
lectures the the activity would present
the latent variables themselves and the
variability that we would see would
correspond to the uncertainty so
liability we see in the responses we
don't correspond to the sampling process
of the distribution
often an example is given that is
suggestive of the sampling hypothesis
which is the example of the Necker cube
or by local delivery and so there's been
some work trying to relate this
phenomenon with some models that would
actually have bimodal posterior
distribution and be sampling from this
bimodal distribution where the two modes
would correspond to the two
interpretation and using algorithms such
as MCMC they can reproduce dynamics of
transitioning from the modes that are
very similar to what we see
experimentally so I often people think
of this kind of phenomena as sampling
from a bimodal distribution and and from
time to time transitioning to the other
mode I'm interested of course in the
neural substrate of priors and how we
can think about this and that's actually
difficult people are thinking about this
is many different ways so you can think
about where are those priors living in
the brain there is for example some fMRI
study where they do an experiment very
similar to the experiment we've done and
looking at where you would see the
signature of the prior in the visual
stream and whether the activity you see
in v1 is already the posterior is the
likelihood and they find they find that
there is evidence even in v1 of the
combination already of prior and
likelihood some people think of priors
in terms of top-down the inputs those
feedback projections which we don't
really know what they do they might be
predicting and might be the prior people
try some people try to look at
expectations in terms of viability in
in the activity of neurons and for some
people this is going to be more like an
increase in activity and actually
expectations and attention are very
similar phenomena so sometimes they
behave the same and then so expectations
would relate to increase in activity
gain modulation upward but also
adaptation can also be thought of in
terms of an expectation and so
adaptation as you know is again
motivation that word so and it may
depend on whether the signal is actually
relevant or maybe when it's 11 it's
actually up word and not 11 time where
there's an adaptation finally I wanted
to describe two ideas if I have time
some people have been thinking of priors
in terms of the tuning of the neurons
others in terms of the baseline so I'll
just describe quickly add in the tuning
of the neurons again this is paper by
Eric Simoncelli but also there's other
work coming also to similar ideas here
so again they try to relate biases in
terms of perception of orientation they
extract the prior with these Bayesian
tools and they can also compare the
prior with the statistics of the visual
images another thing we know is that in
v1 there are more neurons tuned to
horizontal and vertical than other kind
of orientation and so they put
everything together and they show that
if you have a simple decoding scheme
like a population vector which is
reading from a population of neurons
which is you know more genius this you
know me in a margin 80 in itself will
act like a prior and they show with
simulations that you can you can mimic
this displays you know the influence of
this Bayesian prior just with this
population vector reading out from this
in homogeneous population so maybe we
can think of the inner majority of the
different features of neurons in terms
of a prior trying to bias the activity
towards more frequent or expected
features that's true but you said you
could change
200 trials so that has a lot of
implications for what mechanisms of
changing that the networker actually I
don't think you can change the bias to
watch the Cardinals though and so in our
experiments we have huge biases towards
accountants and everything so just to
come back to this I think there's a
question the mechanism there's in my
mind there are multiple different
mechanisms and multiple different
timescales there's no reason why the way
priors are implemented in the brain
should have one form everything
everything we think about in terms of
plasticity memory is a prior adaptation
as well and and so I think all these
mechanisms can coexist
I don't know about the cerebellum but
but in the price that we manipulate in
our experiments for example I expect to
see in v1 it changes in the neural
activity at the timescale that we are
seeing the changes whereas for for
example this this bias towards the cut
in ER I don't expect a time scale of an
experiment to see to see any change
so yeah so and finally an interesting
idea that is out there is that maybe the
baseline activity of neurons represents
a prior conviction and that's an idea
has been proposed by Mattie languages
official and others so and they looked
at the spontaneous activity in ferrets
and they compared the structure of the
spontaneous activity with averaged
evoked activity with the idea that if
it's a prior it should look like
averaged evoked activity for those
animals when with the evoked activity
corresponding to the naturalist is seen
statistics thinks that the summary of
their previous experience so that's what
they've done in this quite influential
paper they looked at activity in v1
multicellular activity and they looked
at the statistics of spontaneous
activity and evoked activity for natural
scene statistics but in that case it's
the movie The Matrix and also evoked
activity that is evoked by simple
stimuli like gratings artificial stimuli
and what they show is that the stat the
measure so they look at a distance
between the this priority distribution
of the despondence activity and the
average evoked activity and they show
that with age the spontaneous activity
looks going is going to look more and
more like average evoked activity for
naturally seen statistics and not like
average evoked activity for artificial
stimuli just like you would expect if
this baseline activity really represents
a prior so general expectation about
what is plausible to appear in the world
which i think is interesting idea which
yet needs to be further testing
that's like my almost my last slide how
approximate inference would be
implemented in the brain so basically we
don't know we have a lot of idea coming
from machine learning so this
approximate inference could involve
sampling or deterministic approximation
method for some people some people are
interested in vinyl approximation which
is a predictive coding for some people
some people think that predictive coding
is the way Bayesian inference is
implemented in the brain and and some
people and so these people also believe
that this is very interesting now
because predictive coding then would be
a good bridge so if it's the algorithm
by which Bayesian inference is
implemented so we know a lot about how
predictive coding can be implemented in
neurons you know how donna will tell us
more about this and so if creative
coding is the algorithm then yeah we
have a bridge between what neurons do
and the computation
and so there are some labs like colistin
and which are actually very prominent in
computational psychiatry with which
start from the belief that predictive
coding is the way the brain is using is
is implementing business
so as a conclusion so I think Bayesian
models I think enough everybody maybe
agrees that patient models are very
successful at the behavioral level as a
benchmark for performance and that that
the yeah they can be used to look at
these internal models where we still
have lots to understand about how those
internal walls are round and the limits
of this learning we are as you
understood we have at the moment very
simple models is very simple paradigm
I'm interested in the application to
psychiatry and whether this is going to
be ultimately useful for the clinic
there's a lot of confusion about the
claims that there are of debates which i
think is very interesting clearly
there's a problem a little bit about
bridging this computational level and
the neurobiological level and and so we
need more models so there's a lot of
mothers that are in proposed as well
like a proof of feasibility that neural
networks can do Bayesian inference but
whether we can actually determine what's
being done in the brain is is it's a
very difficult question so neural
implementation is largely unknown and so
that are taking in my lab has been to
look at very simple fires very simple
explained expectation now so we are
going to look at fMRI for this kind of
experiments try to understand better
thank you very much well mostly a
supportive comment for their group that
believes that roughly you could think
you the cortex is in the banks so you
can see you think of the upper bank is
that prior for the lower level below and
in that when you do another constraint
is learning algorithms and so when the
learning algorithm is running is very
important to sample the evolving prior
maximize maximum likelihood a
winner-take-all it have the thing
converging the other thing is if you're
forced to burn in the prior of the
statistics of the incoming signal so you
have to doesn't have to be Gaussian you
just have to accept that statistics of
the input the other the only other
comment I would make is that things like
Edison maybe everybody knows this but it
seems like a hidden piece of information
is Judea pearl in but maybe twenty years
ago came up with Bayes Nets and then so
if you have graphs which have no loops
then and where there you have the
conditions they represent conditional
probabilities that are the length then
you can have an incredibly fast
inference over the whole whole never
with witches you can do a big problem of
these in one sweep and so where you have
the constraint you can just pin the
neurons you know and then everybody else
ponies up there the appropriate
probabilities and in in in that thinking
about that it's important to think about
the whole cortex because a lot of times
we have these vulcanizing ideas of what
the museum is a for face area what is
that where is it get deco and here and
working with our children show that
people watching movies the whole
coordinates lights up so that's one
that's one big network is working and so
we I would say on the table is with at
least one hypothesis on how the
inference happens and it's already
worked out but yeah I didn't have time
to be with a into the details of the
algorithms that but this yellow work in
the domain of course here
here's the question I have a question
respect to the experiment that you had
morning dots and different
in two directions there was a high
probability so it's also a phenomenon
which is adaptation like so if you're
passively watching moving dots without
making a scene yet they stop you
discount that direction and which is
kind of has the opposite effect
how do you take an adaptation into
account so we're doing so in our data we
have attractive biases towards the prior
so they as you said it goes in the in
the other direction we don't have
signatures of adaptation which would be
a recursive bias towards the adapter and
we also looked at the influence of one
trial to the next to see if we have
signatures of adaptation and so we
perceived biases and and we don't one
reason is because we operate at very low
contrast probably and in the
temporalities of our sequences
the schizophrenic the schizophrenic
model hey who suggested it then do they
have predictions also from me so
something that we can check what kind of
predictions would you be interested in
they have so that's the thing that's
what we are trying its not-it's mostly
very qualitative at the moment the
claims that are being done and it is
sometimes loosely consistent with some
data for example visual illusions key in
schizophrenic patients
some people find are weaker than in
controls things like that there are some
experiments which are often inspired by
these Bayesian ideas but which don't
involve any Bayesian modeling which are
consistent sometimes with the the fact
that the the prior beliefs at the
perceptual level will be lower and at
the community level will be stronger but
no it's largely untested that's that's
the point so this is the autism
this autism yet so the initial paper
yeah we are flexion please and there's a
lot of work by the group of consistent
at UCL where they think about it in
terms of predictive coding and so they
they also related somewhat to the they
try to neural substrate and dopamine
dopamine hyper so this is what we call
dopamine hypothesis in schizophrenia so
they were the impairment in dopamine and
they the relates prediction error and
dopamine and the idea prediction error
then would be in found in schizophrenia
so that would explain that in family
learnings which would which would lead
to in famines in in these internal
models but it's very qualitative it's a
which is interesting so I came from a
different background maybe not so much
familiar with the literature here our
previous knowledge during our life that
is stored somehow in our brain so as I
mentioned it's stored as the priors and
they like you and these to get updated
as we receive new data so this new data
comes from like the five cents that we
had that Ben's information that we sense
from the environment around us so I was
thinking
where does thinking play player out here
so if we block those five senses and
just think about something so is it
going to change likelihood or if you ask
people to imagine some situation of just
imagining a situation rather than
watching you so for example people are
excited psychiatrists are quite excited
by this kind of tools for example in
depression weather
I don't know if I can answer your
question at all but for example negative
belief so we can use and we've Donna in
the lab trying to use similar tools to
look at so people's behavior and kind of
game-like environment and try to measure
their priors about beliefs
we want for example and so we can we can
we can see that optimistic people for
example I have prior different files
about the likelihood of future we want
and so the question is how you're going
to update those priors and also yes so
then therapy you know can say it's
therapy can you measure the success of
therapy in terms of changing those
priors so so maybe that relates to that
can thinking maybe by itself I can lead
to a plasticity that you can actually
measure with such technique now we just
done that yet but design an experiment
is this you ask people to imagine
something or to think about something
and then you can see if it affects the
prediction you ask somebody to do
something it's kind of you're giving
input through hearing right so I mean so
suppose that Mathematica must solve the
problem and so these are like storing
information is bringing somehow somehow
changing prior years even without seeing
exactly so are there any studies that I
know but
so I think they're like one yeah yeah
with all this Bayesian paradigm there's
two parts to this one you have the prior
and then you have the likelihood now
somebody very early on mentioned that
storing a distribution is very expensive
and it's needless but this is this
applies mostly to a prior I think that
is really a distribution of both but
would like to point out that in all this
is algorithms to describe the only have
any two sample from the distribution yet
a very massive in parallel architecture
brute a lot of noise and it's very cheap
to sample from the distribution with
very expensive like reliably store that
precise value so that that it's not very
hard to start experimenting and the
other thing is we're going to just
mention thinking I think the likelihood
function that's never the saluted
distribution that's about thinking and
about reasoning right if I think about
the cake if it's gonna rain how likely
is it that it's going to be sunny
outside
that's a distribution about it knowledge
that I stored its reasoning this or
something very again I think that
something is close okay good so they
need I think for us to move out of here
but first of all I just want to thank
Peggy again
we